What looks like an alien spaceship—
Is actually a tiny object made up of an air pocket
surrounding a metal ball--plunging through liquid.
The air pocket creates a nearly frictionless surface
and is falling at a constant velocity.
Normally, a solid moving in liquid is slowed down
by friction and drag.
So, how did researchers reduce drag to nearly zero?
By creating a nonwetting surface
using one of two approaches:
Heating up a metal ball so hot that what’s called
a Leidenfrost effect occurs--
where a vapor layer forms
between the ball and the liquid.
Like water beading on a hot stove.
Or coating the metal ball with a hydrophobic
or super water repellent substance.
The balls are then placed at specific heights
above a deep tank.
Here, a 20mm steel ball preheated to
400 °C is dropped at a height of
55 cm into 95°C water.
At impact, an air pocket forms.
It stabilizes into a streamlined shape by shedding
small air bubbles at the tail
until it achieves a constant velocity.
The dropped hydrophobic ball also forms an air pocket
and at similar velocities,
without the need of pre-heating the ball or fluid.
Previous drag reduction schemes
have also used air pockets-
but a very thin layer around the object,
so they basically retained their original shape.
In contrast, the present methods rely on creating
a very large, tear shaped air pocket—
from 5 to 15 times the volume of the balls themselves—
changing the solid sphere into a giant air torpedo.
To determine if drag has been reduced,
researchers then raced the air pocket balls
against plastic projectiles
with matching weights and shapes.
Analyzing the high speed footage,
they found drag was reduced by 90%
compared to the plastic dummies.
Predicting the movement of bodies in fluids
is usually difficult because of resisting forces
but since these new methods
virtually eliminate friction and turbulence,
velocities can be accurately calculated based on
the density of the ball and the volume of the air pocket.
Next, researchers want to nail down exactly
how the shapes of the air pockets are determined.
Since these objects require
so little energy to travel through water--
perhaps these methods could be applied
to energy efficient, high speed transportation
in the future.
Engineers already are releasing bubbles under ships
to reduce fuel costs.
Maybe shaping those bubbles or using them
with hydrophobic coating could speed things along.